всіх турбує тільки одне питаннята
мобілізація потрібна на військовим
очевидно що мобілізація потрібна всьому
суспільству Кабмін відкликав свій
законопроект так Верховна Рада працювати
не може це є неправильно коли Верховна
Рада так працює країна воююча стікає
Кров'ю і здається що парламент має
працювати зранку до вечора на одну мету
посилення України міжпарламентська
діяльність і звичайно посилення збройних
сил України Шановні колеги ми не
завершили розгляд цього питання Я
Оголошую перерву у нашому пленарному
засіданні На жаль ми не встигли
розглянути всі питання порядку денного
Дякую усім за плідну роботу зараз я
Оголошую перерву я Оголошую перерву у
нашому засіданні бездарний абсолютно
пленарний день коли на порядок денний
знову не винесли наприклад питання
відкликання з посади заступниці голови
комітету нацбезпеки і оборони Мар'яни
безуглої яка написала заяву про вихід з
фракції із партії обізвала там свою
партію фракцію якось беззубо і там Ну в
принципі сказала те що є правда не
додала скільки вона доклала зусиль для
того аби ця партія і фракція виглядали
дійсно так бездарно І взагалі ідиотично
я з вами теж погоджуюся і очевидно що
коли Маріана вже сама вийшла з фракції з
партії то постанову про її відкликання з
посади заступниці голови комітету
нацбезпеки треба виносити до залу але
цього не буде стефанчук не отримав таку
відмажку від офісу президента тому
продовжує її захищати виключть будь
ласка мікрофон Тому що оце просто як
якесь дитяче незрозуміле бажання
використати норми регламенту крапка
важливе рішення сьогоднішнього дня
винесли на розгляд зали законопроект 162
це дуже важливий проект аби запровадити
автоматичне убд в нас колосальна
проблема в державі наші вій ві не можуть
отримати статус убд деякі які по року
два роки на нулі служать а отримати
статус учасника бойових дій не можуть
при цьому створення єдиного реєстру
військовозобов'язаних тому що
законопроекти виписані ідеально але з
авторства європейської солідарності
порядок денний не
виносяться як компроміс сюди було Додано
важливу насправді платформу що
стосується єдиного реєстру
військовозобов'язаних який має бути в
країні але на жаль до другого читання
він став гірше за змістом аніж вносився
тому що багато норм туди внесли слуги
які є так само антиконституційними цей
законопроект насправді ну шляхом нашого
звичного шулерства тут в Верховній Раді
як ми це любимо перетворився на збір
даних про всіх зокрема
а серед цього потрібного насправді
кабінету там єдиного реєстру військово
зобов'яз є така норма що Навіть оці
персональні дані наших
військовозобов'язаних не будуть
потребувати їх дозволу на обробку Це не
про
полегшення надання статусу учаснику
бойових дій це про стеження за всіма
українцями це про збір понаднормової
інформації про всіх українців пропонують
вносити туди інформацію про дітей про
навіть немовлят Навіщо це порібно в
реєстрі за згодою може бути але Навіщо
це обов'язкова історія банківські борги
реєстр боржників твої рахунки майновий
стан виїзди всі за кордон навіть
адміністративні правопорушення До речі
це буде стосуватися пана стефанчука коли
Він отримує адміністративну
відповідальність за порушення які він
робить весь час в залі оце інформацію
він буде змушений внести в свій реєстр
військовозобов'язани Я хочу його Від
цього до речі убезпечити і цю норму
треба вилучити з реєстру так само як і
інші бздури які абсолютно не
відповідають реєстру
військовозобов'язаного цивілізованої
країни завдяки нашій позиції змогли
вичистити кілька безуглих абсолютно
безумних норм зокрема про те що в реєстр
військовозобов'язаних наприклад треба
вносити інформацію про адміністративні
правопорушення ми вважаємо що це є
надмірною нормою яка може бути внесена
до цього реєстру яка неє не має
суттєвого значення а отже і є нелогічною
для того щоб її використовувати при
формируванні реєстра
військовозобов'язаних резервістів та
призовників я прошу пана голову
поставити цю поправку також на
підтвердження за 137 рішення не прийнято
з цієї каші яка стосується змісту цього
законопроекту взагалі не є відомим хто
які відомості вносить Та хто буде
споживачем цієї інформації саме тому
Через надмірне збирання персональної
інформації яка є обтяжливою для ведення
реєстра Я пропоную поставити цю поправку
на голосування і не підтримувати її і
одна важлива деталь от таблиця до цього
законопроекту А це ну більше там 500
поправок бачите в нього повключали ну
просто все підряд І сьогодні ми навіть
до кінця не знаємо бо поправки таблиця
з'явилася там декілька годин тому Ну це
неможливо навіть голосувати такі питання
але в нинішній рхоній раді це стало
практикою тому що моно більшість ніколи
не себе не напрягає тим аби вникати в
зміст законів за які вони голосують а
тим більше там іти і читати поправки
точно зможе перемогти Росію точно зможе
перемогти оцей великий уламок радянської
імперії демократична країна демократична
Україна яка будуватиме цю свою роботу на
повазі до свого громадянина на чесній
серйозній розмові із своїм громадянином
і на досягнення ефективних механізмів
власне залучення громадянина до тих
задач які потрібні європейська
Солідарність запропонувала до цього
законопроекту 28 поправок які мали
вичистити звідти всі антизаконні
антиконституційні норми точно не спам А
це інтелектуальна спроба покращити цей
проєкт ви прийняли тільки дві поправки з
них прийнято традиційно тільки дві і
тому в нас є велике питання до змісту
цього за конопроекту ні про яке
автоматичне отримання ОБД тут не йдеться
і знову прийдеться нашим військовим
місяцями доводити під авдіївкою під
бахмутом на інших гарячих лініях фронту
що вони виконують бойові розпорядження і
мають права отримати статус ОБД а отже і
відповідні пільги питання реєстрів воно
прямо пов'язано з питанням мобілізації і
питання мобілізації яке сьогодні
відкладене Да і тому що Кабмін відкликав
свій зако нопроект тому що Ну багато там
порушень Конституції і дуже-дуже
суспільство сприймає чутливо його
сьогодні ні в кого немає сумніву що в
умовах коли деякі підрозділи на
передовій знаходяться вже майже два роки
питання мобілізації комплексного
вирішення цієї проблеми є важливим і
ключовим мобілізація потрібна на
військовим очевидно що мобілізація
потрібна всьому суспільству тому що
альтернативи не існує альтернатив
це власне зникнення держави Отже
європейська Солідарність очікувала що
саме верховний головнокомандувач подасть
законопроект комплексний який буде
вирішувати проблему мобілізації вид
обсяги порядок і строк проведення
мобілізації визначаються Президентом
України тому що це єдина людина яка
володіє всім об'ємом інформації але ні
попри всі дискусії оця проблема
перетворюється на фарс і зайшов до
Верховної Ради законопроект імені
колективної маріяни підписаний чомусь
шмигалем сам шмигаль жодного разу не
прийшов в парламент представити свій
законопроект у мене іноді складається
враження що всі ці законопроекти
спеціально спрямовані на те щоб
якнайбільше розізлити українців
роздратувати їх
налякати але по серйозному із державиз
держава не хоче говорити з громадянами
але навіть слуги визнали що в цьому
законопроекті імені шмигаля не
вирішується проблема оборони країни і
побоялися виносити його на розгляд зали
тому що в
монобільшості голосів під це немає інші
фракції так само надали свої зауваження
всіх турбує тільки одне питання
мобілізація в принципі номер один тема в
країні є багато речей які треба до
працьовувати
та покращувати дуже багато речей треба
виправляти ну ще раз Я Хочу наголосити
позицію європейської солідарності перше
система обороноздатності країни потребує
комплексного рішення і тому зараз уже
має стояти мова про Створення уряду
національного порятунку Який дасть
відповідь і на необхідність там
посилення фортифікаційних споруд
оборони економічної складової яка має
стати фундамент там для мобілізації Я
розумію що тут абсолютно всім що я
говорю і що говорять Мої колеги даруйте
на слові тому що кожен займається в залі
своїми справами Голова Верховної Ради
тре про щось все не буде знову години
запитань до уряду не буде оголошено
Запитів слуги розійшлися Подивіться зала
порожня сьогодні парламент працював пару
годин всі розійшлися і от мене дивує
така неспромо жність правлячої
партії сформувати той порядок денний
який є актуальним для воюючої країни так
Верховна Рада працювати не може це є
неправильно коли Верховна Рада так
працює і це безумовно є абсолютно
неправильно абсолютно неправильно так не
має бути ось так по суті один день був
пленарний в січні слуги три тижні до
того відпочивали але як є підписуйтесь
на наш YouTube канал коменту те
задавайте питання Що вас цікавить в
роботі парламенту будемо відповідати все
буде Україна друзі